[Music]
harmonize with me
you're shining bright I'm your oyster
baby you're my Pearl
really I'd like to start with a an
instrumental song oh I can't wait join
in if you're feeling it I do
[Music]
Bob
[Laughter]
ha ha ha ha
now for any of uh listeners or uh
watches who were wondering what that was
that was the instrumental stylings of
the Antiques Roadshow wonderful one of
the great BBC institutions I think
although at one point I think a dead gun
is the same tune from Jurassic Park yeah
I think there was some uh Jurassic Park
and what was that film that TV show
about um
the horse not Black Beauty Mr Ed there
was another one about a horse kind of in
Cornwall felt like that as well have you
got anything in your house if the
Antiques Roadshow came through your town
you'd say let's take that my grand
she was 100 weren't she yeah and she
loved the Antique Roadshow
antique roadshow Dom
for anyone who hasn't watched it if you
could tell our listeners what that show
is or was is it still on still on tell
people what it is it's an institution
I'd love to the Antiques Road show it's
a road show so it moves through certain
cities comes to your city and if you've
got possibly an heirloom something
that's old it's been in the family and
what you think might be valuable but
you've never really had the full
valuation of it take it to the Antiques
Roadshow and they have people different
experts he's an expert in silver she's
an expert in painting he's an expert in
textiles you line up they give you a
valuation a little history of the thing
and they tell you how much it's worth
and you always watch the Antiques
Roadshow hoping that someone brings in
something that they found in a car boot
sale for six quid and it's a four
hundred thousand dollar painting yeah or
it's a set of six egg cups oh this was
owned by Aaron Berlin right right this
is this is absolutely Priceless yeah it
very rarely happens but there has been
I'm sure you can Google search for
YouTube search the top 10 most amazing
moments in the Antiques Roadshow where
something's incredibly I'll tell you the
number one right now go on
a guy win and you can Google this I'd
love to he win and I can't remember what
he had I think it was a painting good
story
and but anyway they did the valuation
and it was okay oh it's about a couple
of hundred pounds but anyway they got
chatting to the guy and he's he's maybe
about late 70s early 80s older guy been
he was in the war and all that oh God so
he says to them I tell you what I've not
been sick a day in my life
oh no and they said that's amazing what
is your health routine what do you do he
says
he says I take one call
what he says I'll take one clove
he says it's okay he said I'm not
looking at you no don't
he says I take one clove of garlic every
morning
yeah that's okay wow and he says never
been sick a day in my life and they said
you do what I say one clove of garlic
and I put up my bum
and there's no end to that story there's
no joker innocent this guy
swore by it Dom you should maybe try it
well you can if you want I mean a bulb
of Garlic's got probably got a month's
worth of clothes in this so it's not
expensive does it go up and then the
first thing that falls out when he has a
little Joby is a little
oh my God I don't really know the ins
and outs of it but that that episode
more than egg cups with Anne Berlin
that is stuck in my mind I bet the host
was quite kind of confused by the side
swerve comments you look very well I was
like yeah I go for walks every day I've
got a dog I avoid alcohol no I shove
garlic up my ass oh great okay moving on
here's a picture of a boat
I found in the Attic that's great ah so
there you go jump well that's the
Antiques Roadshow fantastic if you guys
have any stories about antiques let us
know but today Billy we're very excited
because we've got a guest haven't we we
have an amazing guest today Dom like
unbelievable I mean I have to give John
a round of applause
you know organizing this because as you
know occasionally on the podcast we go
off on tangents and that will often
bring us to physics and questions of the
known universe and sometimes String
Theory yeah who would you get if you
want to talk about physics and string
theory well you I would say uh kind of
string theory Daft so you'd be a great
guest yeah on a podcast just to kind of
give people a general overview yeah of
quantum physics but if you're looking
for an X expert there is one guy out
there that's written a bunch of books
and is very well respected right
professor
green
what he's probably your number one guest
and we've got him and here it comes I'm
Quentin after this all right here's a
little intro into Brian dream Brian
Greene is a professor of physics and
Mathematics is renowned for his
groundbreaking discoveries and super
String Theory including the core
discovery of mirror symmetry and of
spatial topology change he is known to
the public through his books the elegant
Universe of course the fabric of the
cosmos lovely and the hidden reality
which have collectively spent 65 weeks
on the New York Times best sales list
and sold more than 2 million copies
worldwide incredible The Washington Post
called in the single best explainer of
obtuse Concepts in the world today
Professor Green hosted two Peabody and
any award-winning Nova miniseries based
on his books and is a frequent
television guest joining our friend
Stephen Colbert Steven seven times on
his show and playing himself in an
episode of The Big Bang Theory buddy
let's bring on Brian Green and talk
about all things tiny
hey thank you so much for joining us I
will uh speak on behalf of my colleague
Billy Boyd here who told me when we
started this podcast that his number one
guest on the show would be you sir so
we're very excited is that right
absolutely he's obsessed with all things
String Theory so Billy over to you hello
Mr Brian Green how lovely to meet you
thank you for coming on this show really
love my pleasure thank you thank you
have we started recording are we ready
to go oh we're good it's actually
happening this is actually happening in
the universe or is it or is it in this
universe yes exactly and probably many
others in fact why don't we start with
that
we shall start with universities and is
there only one is that a good place to
start is that well why not we'll just
Dive Right In if you've got Professor
Brian Green why wouldn't we Dive Right
we only have a finite amount of time
with Professor Brian Greene
no you've heard all these jobs okay
um so can we call you Brian or Professor
yeah or Mr Green Brian okay Brian's
great right that's great thank you so
Brian let's start with that we'll do
everything probably from your sort of
point of view so we'll be asking lots of
questions on probably what you think so
do you think
there is more than one universe or is
everything that we see what we see
uh I I honestly don't know the answer to
that and I'm not embarrassed to say that
because there's nobody on the planet who
knows the answer to that question what I
can say is that there are reasons for
taking the possibility of other
universes
as crazy as the idea sounds there are
reasons for taking it seriously when we
pursue the mathematical understanding of
a variety of theories quantum mechanics
being one of them the attempt to
understand the so-called unified theory
that we do with string theory trying to
understand the big bang that started
things off in our universe all of these
approaches wind up suggesting the
possibility that our universe might not
be the whole thing that there might be
these other universes incredible and so
we're willing to take the idea seriously
pursue it but we don't believe it until
we've got evidence and we certainly
don't have evidence for it yet and do
you think that the
the reason that we find it difficult to
think of other universities do you think
that's because of the human mind
thinking of size and we just see the
universe and think that is so huge like
people like yourself have told us how
big the universe is how far galaxies are
apart you know how many billions of
galaxies there are so how can there be
more but I think I read in one of your
book I think it was one of your books
I'm sorry if it wasn't you'd there was
an analogy of if it was a bubble in a
bathtub yeah that that was my book I
think right so so the idea that if you
thought of everything in the universe
and in thought of all of that was a
bubble in a bathtub right then all the
other bubbles would be the other
universities
then that would be a sort of
analogy of of that thinking is that
correct it is but it really speaks
exactly to the intuition that your
question started with yeah when you
think of a bubble in a bubble bath you
think of it as having you know a finite
size yeah and that allows for there to
be other bubbles outside of it but when
it comes to the actual universe or space
many of us just imagine it goes on
forever yeah it doesn't ever stop and
then you've got that puzzle on your
hands well if space in our universe goes
on forever there's no room that would
seem for other universes right and and I
understand that intuition well
it's based upon experience and
experience is what allowed us to survive
through the eons and allowed us to
navigate the everyday world and find the
next meal and and find shelter and so
forth but we've learned that mathematics
is a better Guide to the nature of the
world than our senses and our intuition
and mathematically we understand well
how even if space in our universe goes
on forever there still is room
for other universes and other Realms the
space in our universe need not exhaust
all of the possible places that Another
Universe could reside and so we have no
problem mathematically understanding how
our universe could go on forever and yet
there still could be room for other
universes even though the human mind
has a hard time grasping that idea I
think that's great but I think that's
the thing isn't it the um
as you see our mind is made to do
something and if you understand math
then you you can understand the universe
in another way but I think what you do
beautifully with your books and with
your TV shows is that you can take those
ideas
out of the world of math and and try to
explain it in a different way that
someone who who doesn't have that
mathematical history can sort of try to
get their head around it and I think uh
that is really impressive what you're
doing with that so thank you very much
yeah no thank you and and that is the
point the hope is look these ideas are
so mind-bending that it's tragic that
many people who would be enormously
excited to learn of these things feel
cut off from it because they don't have
a graduate degree in physics or a
graduate degree in mathematics so the
point of my books and many other books
too
is to translate from the esoteric
language that we use when we're doing
the scientific research you know
advanced mathematics and translate it to
just the ideas that anybody who's
willing to put in some effort can
congrats and uh and it's a wonderful
thing when even kids I mean I sometimes
get letters it's always surprised me
from the first time I got one
five-year-old six-year-olds who've uh
read a book of mine or or watched a
television show and have questions and
they either write it themselves or get
their parents to write a question and
and you see a young mind expanding Yeah
by virtue of of encountering these
possibilities of other universes or or
the weirdness of space and time and
relativity or the weirdness of quantum
mechanics so these ideas need to be more
widely discussed and and understood
because it's our heritage as as members
of the single species that's been able
to figure this stuff out Bailey and I I
think take a huge amount of um comfort
and um satisfaction in in being aware of
just how small we are as individuals on
this planet and you know as well as
starting to include the size of of our
solar system and one of the things that
I loved in as Billy was saying earlier
on your ability to make things much more
easier to digest in in your recent book
was
trying to make sense of the stars that
we see in the sky and that everything
seems so clustered together because
we're not able to see distance and Brian
said if you imagine that our planet is
the size of a grain of sugar yeah and
it's based in New York the closest star
is in Connecticut oh wow yeah I just
loved your ability there to be able to
make a a visual picture first for people
not able to understand what they're
actually seeing in the night scale that
was that was an amazing thing to read
yeah I mean the nice guy is um is
wondrous but misleading as you're noting
because when we look at the stars in the
night sky our eyes as you emphasize are
unable to really discern the distances
to the Stars they all more or less look
like they're the same distance up there
on the uh the Cosmic Sphere that
surrounds us it almost looks crowded up
there on a nice clear night but the
reality is all those stars are at vastly
different distances most are very far
away and so it only looks crowded
because the eye tends to compress them
all at the same separation but there are
great range of separations and indeed
the closest one is far away you know
four light years away light years about
a trillion you know Six Trillion miles
so we're talking about you know 25
trillion miles away to the nearest star
wow besides the Sun of course the sun
the sun is the nearest of all but beyond
the Sun
hey Dom green Chef no there's a great
thing where you get food delivered to
your door meal plans you can set it up
it doesn't matter what you like if
you're keto or a Paleo or you just want
to eat healthy it doesn't matter you can
set it up yourself the food gets
delivered to your door along with a
recipe card and then it becomes a game
then you start chopping and doing all
your stuff and try to make it as good as
you can it's a fantastic thing I love it
as well there's a lot of flexibility in
the food that you can pick there's over
30 meal choices that they have some
weeks I'm going crazy in the gym maybe
you want a little bit more protein some
weeks I've been doing a lot of traveling
maybe I want to be leaning more towards
a kind of vegetarian diet maybe a little
bit more fruit than normal you can enjoy
restaurant quality dishes in the comfort
of your own home maybe watching a lovely
film in front of the Telly and here's a
great thing Dom green Chef is now owned
by hello fresh
and with a wider array of meal plans to
choose from there's something for
everyone I love switching between the
brands and now our listeners can enjoy
both brands at a discount with us go to
greenchef.com
onion125 and use code onion one two five
to get 125 off including free shipping
that's greenchef.com
onion125 and use the code
onion125 to get 125 off including free
shipping it's a number one meal kit for
eating well
now William you and I are both busy
people we have busy lives we know it can
sometimes be difficult to carve out that
time to go to your gym get changed do a
workout jump in the shower at the gym
jump back in your car sometimes we just
don't have the time now the great thing
about having a Peloton by means that
you're only a couple of steps away from
jumping on that bike in your house and
enjoying a fantastic workout the
original Peloton bag now costs 400 less
than it used to so now is the perfect
time to start building the momentum to
reach your fitness goals one of the best
investments I've ever done during these
strange times we're all locked in the
house and all that I got myself a
Peloton bank and I love it
and what I love about it is I'll be
doing a day you know when I've I've got
other things to do and I'm not even
planning on having a workout and then I
just say you know what I'm going to jump
on the bike do a 20 minute workout or
maybe a 15 minute workout in a 10 minute
stretch you can do that you can layer it
and see what what it is that you want to
do it's fantastic it's a great thing to
have in a house done
now Peloton isn't just game changing
cardio you can add like Billy said a
strength class to your ride or you
combine cardio and strength into one
workout with bike boot camp to get a
total body fitness experience it's true
Dom and it doesn't matter if you're a
beginner or you're a champion cyclist
you'll find something that will fit your
level with Peloton
experience motivation like never before
with the pellets on back now four
hundred dollars less go to one
peloton.com to learn more
that's all n e p e l o t o n.com
so well can we can we bring it back a
little bit Brian I mean I'm sure you've
you've you've gone through this quite a
bit in some of these interviews but
could we ask you as a as a eight nine
ten year old boy what were the moments
for you where you read a piece of
scientific information that that made
you go down this particular pair
yeah for me it didn't it didn't start
with science per se it actually started
with mathematics I was one of those
nerdy math kids who just loved to solve
problems and and learn areas of
mathematics my dad didn't go to college
or anything he was a high school dropout
but he knew enough of the basics of
mathematics to get me going and he got
me going at a young age you know
multiplying big numbers against other
big numbers that's how I'd spend the
Saturday or Sunday you know unlike
others who might go out and do other
things and when I then learned a little
bit later on that the math wasn't just a
game but that some people use the math
to understand the world
and when I began to understand how that
went I was just utterly thrilling to
recognize that you could sit with a
pencil and a piece of paper and and
determine things about the outside world
you could determine you know the
distances the stars and the qualities of
of the shapes of uh of things that you
see in the environment a hanging thread
you could calculate its shape you know
just sitting down and and thinking and
that to me was just spectacular
amazing so that was yeah so that's and
then
and do you think
ing about that and and and trying to get
kids into math and stuff it makes me
think the the book The Icarus and the
edge of time that you did that I was
lucky enough I um did the performance of
it with the Scottish national Orchestra
and they're fantastic
performance or I I no you weren't there
they were doing it they were doing a
thing on Minimalist composers
and they'd taken that piece and I was I
didn't know the piece at the time and
for anyone who who doesn't know it you
must go out and and watch the movie
there's a movie of it it's brilliant and
um it was uh Brian and Philip Glass who
did this piece together and Alan L the
two artists uh in your neck of the woods
yeah that's great and uh the idea was
the sort of Icarus story wasn't it and
yeah and what I loved about it was
Icarus doesn't die which I think is a
good thing to teach kids is like just
trying something you know in the
original accuracy makes Wings flies too
close to the Sun and Moon and he's he's
dead well this one which if maybe you
could explain it to his brain but it
gives you a sort of um introduction to
um
to relativity uh yeah yeah that's the
point in fact um when I first learned
about the classic Greek myth of Icarus
it really troubled me that the young boy
died because you know he was he was
doing the Bold thing he was exploring
being curious yeah he was curiosity yeah
he was going into the unknown and to die
for that always struck me as the wrong
lesson to learn yeah you know and so and
then that's what really inspired me to
write this futuristic version where the
boy again against his father's warning
goes where he's not supposed to go he
makes a ship and flies to the edge of a
black hole instead of near the Sun and
you're right and this version he does
not die but rather when you're near a
black hole the real physics that
Einstein taught us is that time slows
down so he spends what he thinks is an
hour near the black hole on this Joyride
in a ship but the rest of the outside
world time is going much more quickly
than it is for him so when he comes back
it's not just a few hours later it's ten
thousand years into the future so when
he returns from this exploration he
doesn't die but he does have to
acclimate to a completely new reality
that emerges from his own bold
exploration and that to me is what
science is all about yeah right you
don't die but rather you do have to
change your views of the world when you
explore and you discover new things and
that that's a good thing that's what
science is about and and you're a huge
fan of Einstein right
yeah you could say I'm an Einstein
Fanboy
and he was he wasn't
um afraid to admit that he changed his
mind on a few things and so I think
that's the great thing about science is
this is our knowledge and belief at the
moment but when someone finds something
else they say well that does prove
there's something else or it's slightly
different and uh I think that's a great
lesson as well and my son my son who's
15 now came to see that show when he was
about four or five and it it totally
blew him away that idea and the amount
of questions he had after that
so um maybe that's a good thing to talk
about relativity and and time and black
holes uh because I find that incredible
so that science is
real what you put in that story that if
you get close enough to a black hole
time slows down how do we know that how
do we know time slows down because we
haven't been close to a black hole have
we it's a good question and the answer
is
it doesn't only time doesn't only slow
down when you're near a black hole time
slows down when you're near any source
of gravity
now black hole makes it more dramatic
because the gravity is so powerful that
time slows down a lot but even on the
surface of the Earth you can compare a
clock that's say at the top of a tall
building like the Empire State building
with a clock that's on the ground and
the clock that's on the ground being
closer to the Earth closer to Earth's
gravity time will take off more slowly
on that clock compared to the one that's
at the top of the building and this has
been measured this is not conjectural
and the amount of time difference
between the two clocks is exactly in
keeping with what Einstein's mathematics
predicts so we then just extrapolate
from those and other observations where
time truly slows down in a gravitational
field you just extrapolate that to a
more powerful gravitational field and
you conclude that time slows down even
more in a very specific way dictated by
Einstein's math that's probably why rich
people like to live in penthouses
rich people in some sense you know are
aging more quickly oh yeah so it's the
opposite it'll be like hobbits
so do we know where the closest black
hole to our planet is we don't we we
know for for sure that there's a black
hole in the center of the Milky Way
galaxy but that's you know many tens of
thousands of light years away so it's
very distant but could there be a black
hole nearby that we don't yet know about
not impossible for sure right
that's uh right that's good that's a
good I like these basic questions of
black holes and and like planets it
wasn't long ago when we didn't know
there was other planets right and now
we're seeing it definitely is
oh yeah yeah no there's there's
incontrovertible evidence now for
exoplanets planets that are outside of
our solar system and planets seem to be
commonplace so a great majority of stars
seem to have planetary systems much like
the sun has us and the other planets of
our solar system and just statistical
analysis suggests that many of those
planets would have conditions that are
not that dissimilar to conditions here
on Earth and that's what leads some to
the conclusion that maybe life out there
is commonplace that's not proven by any
means life on planet Earth the rose from
a whole variety of conditions and uh uh
perhaps uh unlikely uh conjunctions of
qualities so maybe life is rare but the
conditions on Earth seem not to be that
special
your most recent book was called to the
end of time is that right yeah
um talks about the death of the sun
which is absolutely terrifying and uh
fascinating and you and the death of
everything else too right right uh you
had mentioned the um seeing the death of
the sun would be a phenomenal thing but
obviously you wouldn't want to be there
that particular book seems to you seem
to be making a very strong point
throughout that whole book that
everything is finite everything dies
which you know again I think Billy and I
take a huge amount of comfort in that I
think some people probably don't but one
of the sometimes if I get into these
conversations with with people about
that particular subject
we'll have and I'm sure you've had this
this um conversation too Brian that they
will say well we we are made of energy
energy doesn't die when we die where
does that energy go I make the comment
that I have some understanding that as
we lose our core temperature some of
that energy kind of dissipates through
US losing the the heat in our body is
that quantifiable down to a zero or is
there a certain number in terms of the
energy that we have insiders that could
potentially be passing into something
else
well I you know I would agree with those
who note that yes we are energy and
indeed we do believe at least so-called
locally in the conservation of energy
that energy really doesn't just
disappear from the universe so the
energy that makes us up I would say all
of it winds up dissipating into the
environment once we dissolve into our
constituent Parts after after we die and
we Decay but the thing that
distinguishes us is not that we have
energy almost everything has energy
right you know my laptop has energy my
coffee cup has energy what distinguishes
US is that our energy is highly
organized and it's the orderly nature of
our energy the orderly nature of how the
particles that carry that energy are
pieced together into the atoms and into
the molecules that make up the cells
that make up the organs and so forth in
our bodies and Order and organization
that is not conserved order and
organization can go away this is the
so-called second law of Thermodynamics
that entropy or disorder is typically
always on the rise so it's not that our
energy is lost but our order is lost
when we die interesting and I think
that's the point you're making in the
new book isn't it that everything is
trying to get that entropy everything is
slowly disorganizing itself so at some
point the universe will just be
universally covered in stuff
won't be tables and chairs and people
will just be stuff right it would just
be the particles yeah the fundamental
particles and so we're living through a
very special Epoch right yeah
cosmological history right we we're we
live during the epoch when organized
orderly structures can persist for a
little while but if you look at the
Grand cosmological timeline from the
beginning until whatever we can call the
end yeah that window when orderly
structures can exist is very tiny and
cosmological scales for the vast
majority of the cosmos things will have
disintegrated into their particulate
ingredients you know electrons and and
other similar particles that will just
be wafting through space and for nearly
an eternity that's what the universe
will be no tables no chairs no people no
consciousness no life just particles
wafting through the darkness you had
mentioned that in the in the death of
the sun obviously the the DraStic
cooling of the planet the the oceans
would freeze over but you you left a
line in in uh that particular statement
that that there might be a a big
possibility of life in the Frozen oceans
deep down there because obviously a lot
of Life can live there potentially as
our solar system struggles with the
death of the sun there could be a little
Frozen element of life in the very deep
oceans that again made me think oh so
much hope for what for what could happen
next you know so it is it is sort of
hopeful I agree because you know as it
turns out there's a lot of radioactive
decay that happens deep inside the earth
that can be the source of energy you
know as the Earth is tugged on perhaps
by other planets and the Sun there can
be friction in the core of the Sun that
generates heat that that might sustain
life but that hope is itself very
short-lived on the time scales that
we're talking about you wait long enough
and all of those sources of energy will
have dissipated too so yeah it does
extend the domain when life in principle
might be able to survive say deep down
into the oceans but you wait long enough
and it all goes away it all ultimately
dies
right John when it comes to deceiving
time and working more efficiently as the
little things that start adding up
hogging up all the time in your day
grammarly premium gives you real-time
suggestions on your rating so you don't
you can get to the next item on your
list in record time
that's a good point William now you know
me I write very fast all right my emails
fast I write my text messages fast and
when I'm sending you messages I'm never
spell checking I'm never looking back to
see if I write something wrong very
often when I'm trying to write the word
and my phone writes ABS instead because
obviously I'm always talking about ABS
so that can be annoying with grammarly
that doesn't happen it does a little
check for you to make sure you're
spelling the right things no more
searching for synonyms grammarly premium
offers suggestions to replace overused
words and phrases fantastic and as you
know John I'm always writing down ideas
movie idea short film ideas anything
that I can make you a huge starring
that's mainly my drive for the day and
grammarly helps me fix all my mistakes
in these fantastic things Clarity
suggestions through grammarly is so
helpful for me because it eliminates all
of the fluff or unnecessary words I can
use when writing helping me get my
points across across
more clearly see grammarly to have
helped with that moment as well so hit
send with more confidence and get your
point across with more effectively with
grammarly premium get 20 off grammarly
premium by signing up at grammarly.com
onion
that's 20 off at g r a m m a r l y.com
slash onion
you know as well as I do how important
gut health is as time goes on and
science continues to learn more and more
about how our bodies work we know that
gut health is associated with the the
general help of your body the mood in
your brain your general outlook on life
the science is clear a healthy gut biome
is key to a healthy lifestyle
and this thing is with people with take
two diabetes Dom they start to lose the
gut bacteria that helps digest fiber and
manage your blood glucose levels now for
those with type 2 diabetes diet and
exercise of course is incredibly
important but we're always looking for
something else that can help
now the best approach emphasizes diet
exercise and a healthy gut microbiome
pendulum glucose control helps fill in
the gaps by providing the first and only
probiotic designed to manage blood
glucose and A1C levels with pendulum you
can feel in control of your levels not
the other way around take control of
your glucose levels today try pendulum
glucose control for 90 days if you're
not satisfied with your levels you'll
get your money back visit
pendulumlife.com to find out more and
use promo code onion for 20 of your
first bottle of membership
that's p e n d u l u m l i f e.com promo
code onion
so let's go right back to the start then
right back to the Big Bang because
there's a there's a part of the big bang
that annoys me and maybe you can you can
help me out here Brian like
and obviously it's to get our head
around everything in the universe was at
one point a tiny nugget of everything
and then it explodes fair enough okay
we'll put our head around that but this
moment of inflation
or is that the right word when when
because Einstein said right if correct
me whenever I'm wrong that nothing can
go faster than the speed of light
but in this Big Bang Theory
the there was a time when everything
went faster than the speed of light how
can that be
well it can be because when you look
more closely at what Einstein actually
said yeah as opposed to sort of a a
quick summary of what he said what he
actually showed is that nothing can move
through space
faster than the speed of light now you
might think that's just sort of a
technical detail why does it matter but
it matters because in the early Universe
when everything was expanding everything
was rushing away from everything else
yeah it was space itself that was
swelling at a speed faster than the
speed of light nothing was actually
moving through space faster than the
speed of light it was just the substrate
space itself was stretching faster than
the speed of light and nothing in
Einstein's depiction
constrains the rate at which space
itself swells it only constrains the
rate at which you know a baseball or an
object goes through space right and
that's not the relevant thing when
you're talking about the expansion of
space itself so basically we're seeing
the Big Bang is basically space being
created
and it's being created in an expansion
and a sort of inflation sort of way and
then once that's done then everything
inside it can move but everything in
there can't move faster than
you've explained it to me Brian
thank you because I've never got that
and now I've got that
well we can take that one off the list
take that one off
even even today even today there are
examples of that phenomenon because
distant galaxies if they're far enough
away yeah they move away from us faster
than the speed of light but not because
they've got like some rocket engine
that's causing them to move through
space again the swelling of space
continues
space is still expanding and as it
swells it's driving galaxies if they're
far enough apart they're driving them
away from each other at a speed that's
faster than the speed of light I didn't
know that right I didn't know that
either
let me ask you a
theoretical question Brian but you're
the right person to ask theoretical
questions too since that is a huge part
of you know what you do for a living
if you were stood on a on a planet
witnessing the big bang with your bare
naked eyes what would you see in front
of you what would that be
well it's it's slightly hard to address
precisely that question because that
planet itself couldn't be there if
you're witnessing the Big Bang it
actually emerges from the process but
put that to the side yeah you could be
floating in space whatever yeah so so
right yeah
so the universe itself space itself
would be
pretty uniformly filled with an energy
field now your eyes aren't really
attuned to see that energy feel but
let's put that to the side as well let's
say that energy field looks like yellow
or hot or orangey it would be a uniform
glow of that color if if you could see
this energy field and as space expanded
that energy would spread out and
ultimately the temperature would come
down and so were your eyes sensitive to
that you would notice a change in say
the color of the ambient environment and
so for a long time long on cosmological
scales there wouldn't be anything
interesting happening it'd be a pretty
uniform environment whose temperature
would be steadily decreasing over time
and ultimately structures begin to
coalesce out of that uniform energy
field giving your eyes to particles and
collections of particles called stars
and planets and then you could be on a
planet looking out as we currently are
and beholding the result of that whole
process
I know you you might not be into this
sort of thinking but that is so if you
look at the sort of ancient spiritual
thinking that's basically what they see
as well isn't it that there was energy
and then energy became things yeah and
basically they're saying
to be enlightened or whatever just try
and get into that energy again and stop
thinking about the things
and uh and as poetry and as metaphor I
think that's beautiful and and I think
that it's wonderful that ancient people
and ancient civilizations tried to
find a coherent way of thinking yeah
about reality and our relationship to
that reality so all that's quite
wonderful the thing to bear in mind
though is it doesn't go beyond the
Poetry or the metaphor the thing that
science can do is it takes those ideas
it makes them precise it puts
mathematics behind it allowing us to
make predictions that we can go out and
look at the night sky and measure to try
to confirm or or deny these predictions
refute them and that's not what any of
these ancient Traditions are able to do
so sort of as a a qualitative poetic
metaphorical description of reality I
think these are are beautiful
descriptions
distinguish itself though yeah no
absolutely but um I do think Quake
strange that these ancient had had this
thought of this
you know that everything is energy and
it's just quite you know it's quite
impressive that they have this these
images for some reason yeah profound but
I'm I'm guessing that maybe if these
ancient uh communities were able to
access some of the things that we know
of now like meditation or elements of
rhythmic breathing or yeah yeah plant
medicine things like that you can get to
those places yeah that's kind of
euphoric thoughts like like Brian said
it doesn't doesn't have a massive amount
of evidence and and theory behind it
um but the other thing to bear in mind
the other thing to bear in mind is that
language changes over time and so what
we mean by words like matter and energy
and so forth has a different connotation
than perhaps what those words may have
meant in an ancient tradition in ancient
text and I think it's fine to draw a
dictionary an association between the
words as we mean them today and similar
Concepts that find their way into
ancient traditions
that's a great thing to do but again it
is one of analogy and metaphor and
poetry as opposed to rigorous
description of the world sure yeah
absolutely one of the toughest
conversations that I get involved in my
my father was a science teacher for all
of his life and my brother is a science
teacher and I I come from a family that
is deeply entrenched in science and I'm
sure you have this too Brian is when
people say well X Y and Z is just a
theory and you say well no that's
scientific theory which is completely
different from the theory of the moon
mean being made of gem scientific theory
is scientific fact but they hang
themselves on this idea of well that's a
theory in the same way that you know my
legs are made of rubber and trying to
get people over that uh issue that they
have it's it's this shame I understand
why why the word is stuck but it's a
shame that the word theory means
something different when you're talking
about science as opposed to the
dictionary definition of theory that we
often Bandy around Willy yeah but part
of the problem there is that I think
this is a self-inflicted wound to some
extent because scientists themselves
don't always use the word theory in a
consistent manner I mean the two words
that really should be used are
hypothesis and theory and a hypothesis I
think is closer to the colloquial
meaning of theory you just throw out
some idea that maybe this is the
explanation for why this or that
happened in the world that's a
hypothesis right when the hypothesis is
tested and subject to observation and
experiment and if it comes through that
rigorous testing then it deserves to be
called a theory now the problem is I
work on something called super String
Theory super String Theory really should
be called super string hypothesis we've
been developing these ideas they're
mathematics but they have not yet been
tested they have not yet been subject
object to that confrontation with data
and so we scientists shouldn't call it a
theory we should call it a hypothesis
but for whatever historic reasons we
call it super string theory and thereby
muddy the language muddy the water
I don't even know what it's called but
when there was two maybe it's electrons
or protons who were together are then
apart
and something happens to one it'll
happen to the other again we're back
under the speed of light sort of thing
but no matter how far apart they are
it's those will affect each other almost
instantaneously yeah yeah now this is uh
what you what you're referring to is
called quantum entanglement yes exactly
yeah and it was uh it was discovered in
the early days of quantum mechanics by
Erwin Schrodinger one of the pioneers of
the subject but it was really Albert
Einstein
who I think was most troubled by this
quality of quantum mechanics where as
you say you can have two particles they
interact for some period of time and
then you separate them and regardless of
how far you separate them whatever you
do to one particle somehow influences
the other instantaneously now you'd say
oh my God what about again nothing going
faster than the speed of light
and the the math and the theory gets by
you might say by the skin of its teeth
because as it turns out the interaction
is more a correlation in behaviors
there's no way to send information a
signal from one particle to the
entangled member of the pair and it
turns out that's enough
to make this technically compatible with
Einstein's Declaration of nothing going
faster than the speed of light but
Einstein was not happy with this idea he
thought it would be the downfall of
quantum mechanics and he wasn't a great
fan of quantum mechanics and liked that
it had a potential downfall so he put
this forward in the paper as a downfall
of quantum mechanics but it turned out
it's not a bug it's not a problem of
quantum mechanics it's a wondrous
feature of quantum mechanics that now
has been experimentally confirmed so
what Einstein thought would be the death
knell of quantum mechanics is now the
most spectacular quality of the theory
that distant objects can behave as
though they are right next to each other
he called it something didn't he he had
a spooky action
because you know so they could be so far
apart but if you turn one up the other
one instantaneous and is the this brings
us on to I think a lot of people
listeners might be interested in all
right this is all very good and you know
we can think about these things and but
what does it actually do for life on
this planet just now and am I right in
saying that that is um quantum computers
use that use that theory now
but does anyone actually know what's
going on how why that happens and yeah
yeah and so I'm happy to answer the
question I'll just preface it by saying
I'm a great fan of convincing people
that
looking for Value in science by how it
affects everyday life may not be the
right measure I'm I'm a hundred percent
with you Brian I think the whole reason
we're on the earth is just to think
about stuff and just you know try and
work out and have fun but I know a lot
of people that's always the thing with
NASA and it's always the thing what does
it do you know what yeah so but
nevertheless I mean quantum entanglement
does do a lot for us and as you as you
note it is an essential part of this new
approach to computers this approach
called quantum computers which as they
now are in an early stage of development
but the
supposition and belief anticipation is
that one day quantum computers will be
commonplace and they will be potentially
far more powerful far faster than any
computer that we've had so far and at
the core of that is this Quantum process
called quantum entanglement but
something a little bit more mind-blowing
is that quantum entanglement allows us
to carry out teleportation
everybody
you know teleportation is this weird
idea where you you take an object over
here and somehow you make it appear over
there like we're all familiar with it
from Star Trek and so forth
um nobody can do teleportation of of
human beings so I don't want to be
misinterpreted here but there are
scientists today who teleport individual
particles
from one location to another in fact
there's a physicist named Anton
zeilinger you should have him on the
show sometime yes he teleports particles
from
um Tenerife to La Palma you know two of
the Canary Islands 90 miles apart and
uses this quantum entanglement to be the
backbone of how he's able to teleport
these particles so the next question of
course is well can we go beyond
teleporting single particles when can we
do it for macroscopic objects and people
I have no idea and and I can't imagine
that the protocol that's being used for
particles can be scaled up to work for
the huge number of particles in the
human body but I'm one of those people
who will never say never I don't know
maybe one day will be clever enough and
be able to do that but I but I tell you
you the first teleporter that's
developed if it happens in our lifetime
I will not be the first person that
steps in I can assure you of that and
somebody else is gonna no space
about that once it wasn't great
Billy and Dom eat the world
Brian we could talk to you all day and
you're an absolutely fascinating human
being uh we are running out of time and
we do do a regular feature on this show
called Billy and dummy the world you've
you've um you've recommended a fantastic
ice cream to us that John is going to
bring in whilst we eat the world I'm
sure we still have some questions for
you but we are on a ticking clock here
Billy so if you've got burning questions
for Professor Green there is there is
many but yeah we will go into a scream
for a bit but
you're gonna have some vegan ice cream
we're gonna eat some van luo
Luellen what is that right how do we say
it van Lee I don't even know how it's
pronounced I I know what it looks like
in the logos
it's dairy free dairy free ice cream now
you're a dairy free uh string theorist
is that correct I am a dairy free I'm
actually more than that I'm animal free
I don't need any products of animal
origin whatsoever good for you how long
have you been vegan oh man that's going
on um that's going on 30 years now wow
wow okay yeah and was that just
something that you did to try it out and
it's stuck no it's I I was a vegetarian
since I was nine because I ate my mom's
spare ribs and they were so vile and I
realized that they were ribs and that
just completely grossed me out so I
stopped eating meat but um about 30
years ago I then went to an animal
sanctuary in Upstate New York and
learned about the dairy industry and how
they just destroy these animals they
turned them into like milk producing
factories it's really horrible and and
after learning about that I just I just
couldn't go back that was it well good
for you man I mean it's amazing but you
yeah so it's like putting the two things
together is quite
strange because you're saying
everything's made of quarks so you know
you know I mean there's a kind of
strange sort of uh disposition I agree I
love it I love it but I love it I love
that you're worried about living things
and Consciousness and yeah good but
that's the point that there is a serious
point in there which is you're right
some people do say to me hey if it's all
made of strings what do you care whether
the strings are vibrating this way or
that just you're eating strings or
quarks and so forth and my answer is we
look at the world and we analyze it with
different levels of explanation so yeah
at the particle level it's all just
particles quarks and so forth but I do
care about how those particles are put
together I do place value on on life and
Consciousness even though it's all just
particles that organization matters to
me and I don't want to eat that
organization yeah no you're absolutely
good for you Brian now as I said could
you bring in a couple of spoons Johnny
Boy
so we have a honeycomb flavor and a
Sicilian pistachio I'm gonna hold on to
the pistachio for a second Billy I know
this pistachio weather
now as I said Brian we are oh we've got
both of them here oh they're on a plate
these are just these are just to show
our wonderful audience at home so here
we go here's the ice cream we'll we'll
show up in a second Brian in the finite
I'm out of time that we have and in in
the hopes that we can continue to blow
our audience's minds and turn them onto
your books and your life's work
other things where if you're if you have
two or three minutes with someone at an
airport or someone that's signing you're
signing an autograph with that says
please blow my mind tell me something
that's going to keep me up at night
because I just know this is going to
bend Billy's brain is there anything
that that comes to your mind that it
blows your mind so many things certainly
quantum entanglement comes into it the
weirdness of time and relativity that we
discuss but I guess I would also focus
upon my strong belief that we do not
have free will
a free will
is something that our minds make us buy
into we think that we are the ultimate
author of our actions but when you
realize that we are nothing but
collections of particles fully governed
by the laws of physics you realize
there's no opportunity for us to
intercede in the lawful progression of
those particles and and everything we
think everything we do every action we
undertake is nothing but our particles
moving this way or that Under full
guidance by the laws of physics so
there's no place for us to end run those
laws and intercede and thereby exert the
kind of free will that our intuition
suggests to us that we have but we don't
so so in let's say I leave this building
today and I walk across the street and I
get hit by a car that's been predestined
by the physics that I'm limited by
here's the beautiful thing it it's not
been predestined in the way that I think
that you mean because our world is
quantum mechanical as we were talking
about before and in a Quantum Universe
our universe the laws only predict the
probabilities for one or another outcome
so there's some probability that you'll
be hit by that car but it's not
predetermined in the sense that that
outcome is uniquely specified by the
equations the point is you have many
possible outcomes but you don't pick
you don't choose which one happens
that's part of the unfolding of physical
law brilliant I love it this is great
you should have a bite of ice cream yeah
come on now this is dairy ice cream well
we're going to try this is dairy free so
do you know Brian what makes up the
ingredients of this ice cream I think it
may change from one to the other but I
imagine it's coconut milk
almond milk potentially soy milk you
have to look in the ingredients there
let's have a look okay I'll tell you
John yeah
what it says have cream
what that's what it says on the thing
maybe oh you know what you may not have
gotten the vegan version
especially green here it comes in both
vegan and non-vegan
oh come on guys John you should be
ashamed of yourself I went to the I went
to the place I'm gonna be fired on that
one yeah Brian John has let us down a
few times over the weeks but I think
this is the worst one he's ever done
we're eating milk and eggs and cream in
front of a strict vegan I just read what
I'm just trying to look at the
ingredients here and it says eggs plenty
of them oh come on come on Johnny Boy
John well we apologize deeply uh excuse
the same word yeah I'm deeply hurt I'm
hurt so sorry about that just to let you
know almost everything in in this ice
cream will offend you Brian it's made
with cream milk egg yolks sugar
pistachios and salt so it's expensive
across the board but I'll tell you what
it's tasty
um Brian we are so sorry on your own
time on your own time you should try the
vegan version we will absolutely I
promise you that we will do the vegan on
another episode but are we still giving
this one I think we have to give it
marks because this is Billy and dummy in
the world we give it we give things
marks out of ten and I think we're gonna
have to keep doing that Brian even
though it's not what you suggested no
definitely I mean how is it I mean is it
good it is good but I would like to try
the the vegan version to be honestly is
absolutely delicious
um yeah we recently were on your friend
Stephen Colbert's show which was
fantastic and he was recently on our
show we watched your
appearance in which you had Stephen be
part of an experiment where his voice
affected uh a a laser is that right or
the way that the laser um reacted with a
surface it's for Gravity waves wasn't it
gravity yeah it was a demonstration of
the kind of process that happens in
gravitational waves where a disturbance
in the fabric of space-time affects
laser light that we are able to detect
and Steven in some sense played the role
of the gravitational wave through his
booming voice
what do you say science is great I think
you just said science science yeah yeah
but you've been on his show multiple
times I know that Stephen Colbert is is
is quite a deeply religious spiritual
man also obviously has a very strong
connection to the work that you do have
you and Stephen got into some of these
slight contradict addictions that can
occur with a religious spiritual life
and scientific life has he made peace
with that yeah you know I mean the only
conversations that I've really had with
Stephen are the on air conversation then
on air you know in the old days he
played sort of a character yeah that
would come out with you know extreme
views and so forth so that really wasn't
him you know in the new newer show it is
Steven playing himself he's deeply
interested in the scientific ideas and I
have to tell you he understands them and
he knows them because he always comes up
with questions that are spot on that
that never came up in any of the of the
pre-conversation whatsoever so he really
knows his stuff well but I'd love to get
into that conversation with him but we
know we never have you know the
religious versus the scientific
religious orientation he's a huge fan of
Lord of the Rings and we do this show
because of Lord of the Rings have you
ever read Lord of the Rings brain I'm
embarrassed to say I have not well
that's just like you haven't had vegan
ice cream you know I uh I need to hang
my head in shame here because I I have
not
that's a good one I tell the story
because I have it in my future I still
have it to look forward to well you
still have time yeah um it won't be your
choice though Brian
exactly I can't take the blame for it
either well that's another the issue of
blame is the subtle one so I won't go
down that trajectory but yeah I've told
this story quite a few times but my my
lovely mum was coming to visit me in New
Zealand with my dad and my dad had read
Lord of the Rings multiple times my mum
had never read it and I said to my mom
you have to read Lord of the Rings
because you're gonna meet Pippin and
Aragon and Golem and she said oh I don't
want to read about magic and wizards and
goblins and elves it's not really my
mom's thing and I said to my mum it's
not about that it's about people it's
about characters it's about it's a human
story so I think some people can get
quite put off
by the magic and by you know the the
kind of you know what what some people
would would dismiss as kind of silliness
but um it is one of my favorite reading
experiences of all time so I do
recommend it I will do that I probably
to be honest Brian to relax I read your
books I enjoy them more than novels most
of the time I feel like reading about
string theory and quantum physics and
how the universe may work I just find
that so relaxing and and and I think
your books are wonderful so thank you
very much for that right yeah the
elegant Universe was the first one that
I read of yours and it just absolutely
blew my mind and then I read uh till the
end of time over the weekend and uh
phenomenal just incredible and like that
thing that we've talked about so many
times the feeling of knowing just how
small we are is such a comforting
feeling you know yeah yeah well should
we give these some scores so that we can
let Professor Green go we score we score
this ice cream in three categories
flavor
uh Aesthetics and youthfulness
usefulness how how useful is the food so
for Taste storm I'm going to go first
okay on you go it's a 9.8 oh wow you
love it and there's some of the best ice
cream I've ever tasted really that's
great fantastic I'm giving it a 9.5 I
loved it too but 9.8 that's lofty
um Aesthetics I mean it's ice cream
isn't it I mean it's not it's not um
what about the the little box that comes
in the packaging yes nice very simple
very minimalist I wonder if the uh if
the vegan one is made from recycled
materials and all that kind of stuff
it's yeah it's just
it's at 7.2
and then in terms of usefulness well I I
assure you uh Brian I will definitely
buy the vegan version to see how I feel
about that because having a vegan ice
cream in your freezer is a great idea
guilt-free ice cream but in terms of
usefulness I mean it's an ice cream put
in a smoothie if you get the non-vegan
one you can really embarrass yourself in
front of uh professor of physics and
Mathematics yes that's helpful so it's
useful that way I mean
I don't know how useful it is it's not
that it's just before for me it's a it's
a sex a slave and then it's really
that's generous yeah yeah well you know
you could make an ice cream cake from it
I think well we how useful is the ice
cream cake well exactly
Brian we've absolutely loved spending
time with you and I'm sure you hear this
all the time we could we could talk to
you forever I know Billy's been
vibrating for the past couple of weeks
knowing that you're coming on the show
thank you so much for your time thank
you
no it's been really wonderful thank you
very much Brian and please keep writing
those books and and making your TV shows
and everything that you do to help us
out and uh yeah just a real treat thank
you very much thank you very much
enjoyed it thank you sir see ya bye bye
well that was the always fascinating
Professor Brian Greene he knows stuff
you know stuff all about the universe
and the ins and outs and the big stuff
and the smoke Stuff felt like we barely
scratched the surface but I wonder if
maybe with someone like that you always
feel that way because he's dealing with
massive things and Tiny things so
everything yeah smallest of small Quacks
strings to the biggest to big was the
biggest thing
the biggest thing ever biggest thing in
the universe elephant's ass
correct yeah
thank you points for me well amazing oh
I forgot we had uh some gifts sent to us
we have guest house bye and there's a
lovely note here hang on I'll read this
out while you hold up some wonderful
things hello boys says Steph
here are some gifts to help decorate the
new studio now we're not in the new
studio yet we will be well will we do
uh you like the cross stitch so much
that I stitched another one so you could
have one each uh Steph that's very sweet
I want to learn how to cross stitch she
says no this is me talking all right
because I was going to say she knows how
to maybe I'll learn it maybe that'll be
my next skill she also says big thanks
to everyone involved brackets not John
because he keeps messing stuff up
she didn't say that bit
the the podcast is absolutely lovely
says Steph and her
um Instagram handle is
click and tuner that's
k-l-i-k and tuna or as the Americans say
tuna click and tuna click and tuna buddy
you like them fish
anyway she sent us a lovely cross stitch
of Billy well actually Marion Pippin uh
levitating an onion it seems levitating
an onion using nothing but the power of
the pipes and then two wonderful framed
pictures one of me and Dom in human form
and one of me and Dom in Hobbit form and
what are we saying around the outside of
that image I'll watch your back if you
watch mine which was the thing that I
wrote to you in a card on the first day
of filming which I'd forgotten all about
you have no memory of it today do you
still not remember no no so it doesn't
ring a bell at all and then this other
one which is fantastic that's Marion
Pippin maybe on weathertop enjoying a
wonderful raw onion well there wouldn't
be tame on weather so no maybe uh in the
Shire after a Long Day's uh gardening
perfect enjoying a wonderful Roar on you
so thank you lovely thank you if there's
anything you guys want to send in to us
I'm sure you can there'll be a an
address somewhere there's probably an
address but if not you can always email
us and someday we'll send you the
address you can email us at the
Friendship onion at castmedia.com or you
can send us a voice note at
speakpipe.com forward slash the
friendship on you we're also on YouTube
if you guys are watching you know all
about that and there's a Spotify
playlist that includes all of our funky
songs which is the Friendship onion be
mindful there are some people pretending
to be us on Spotify so you need to look
for the official one look for the
official one and uh if you do review the
show don't forget to take a screenshot
and tag Us in it we'll stick it up on
our Instagrams or we'll read them out
here on the Friendship onion friends
we'll see you next week I'm off to read
some Brian Green see ya bye
[Music]